Okay, we are ready to get started on today's zoom call and as you're on you can jump on and jump off anytime you want and this is being recorded.
So we will be able to see it afterwards. So you're going to be able to see my screen and today's call is going to be on the Q&A on the right machine.
So for you rife experts maybe you can add some little pieces to this or when we do get this posted up on our Facebook page and elsewhere.
If you have any other caveats that you have become so acquainted with that you might be able to share other things.
So people in them are using the right machine a long time. This is really easy to understand and you might we've had patients that have brought in little carry cases that they built that they because they are really handy people and we've had people make carry cases out of laundry baskets where the wires can come through and everything fits together so they can move it around.
I'm a pretty handy person and think that it would be pretty easy to do that.
We've had a patient that you would try it was thinking about marketing a carry case for it. So I don't know if they've ever gotten anything harder than that, but we keep ours in our room in our bedroom and that's just kind of our rife spot.
Now we use our rife every night while we sleep as you know my wife had melanova at the time of this recording the almost five years this coming October.
But we still run it every night or just about every night some nights I forget to turn it on but most every night we run it and we run it on the programs that I created for her and for me.
That the ball flies between us in the bed. We'll talk a little bit more about placement and ideas for that.
But this here is an older model actually a liberator if you have this model and this picture I should take my own pictures actually stole us off the rife's website shows the lighted ground.
I think that none of my patients are very few of my patients have but that's certainly not necessary.
Okay, so one of the things I tell everybody is that the rife machine is not a magic wand.
However, that being said, you know, there are no magic ones in cured if we've seen tons of miracles with this thing.
So we've seen some really cool things that maybe it wouldn't say miracles but we've seen some really cool things using it not only for cancer and not only for Lyme disease but when patients use it for other things.
It's in my mind you guys have this tool, you know, you have this very valuable tool and most people I would argue under use it.
So it's what it's you have a tool that's under utilized. It's it's it's kind of sad. Now maybe everybody's super healthy and they don't have any issues. So, but I always tell people.
So I'll tell you again that you have this wonderful tool. It should be your first go to guide in anything that you have going on.
So make this your go to guide in any health issue that you got going on. So if you have headaches, try running the headache program.
If you have a skin rash, run a program for rash or virus or fungus, you have foot fungus, run your foot fungus program.
There are almost 2000 programs that we put on your rifle sheet that can be used for just about everything.
The other question that we get from a lot of people is that are you ever going to burn the ball about or are you ever going to run the machito to the sheet I personally have at home.
I think is a seven year old machine. So we have never blowed a fuse. We've never blowed a transistor. We've never, you know, damaged the bulb.
You know, we've never had to replace anything on it and it's still the original computer, which that's the biggest surprise.
That's the biggest problem we have with the rifle sheet that we were honest with you are not a PC person anymore.
I am definitely a back person because PC's just don't seem to hold up.
That's another thing that sometimes I forget to tell people maybe it's best if you don't connect the rife your rife computer to your home internet.
Because that's where you're going to have more. I think that's why we maybe don't have problems with our computer because we don't have a connected to the internet.
Because that's where you'll pick up a lot of viruses and stuff.
If you ever go on the web or are connected to your internet, so that might be a good idea that sometimes I forget to tell people.
So we get a lot of testimonies from patients that say that they use the rife or whatever for their, their nephew and their, you know, they've, they saw some really cool things with it.
So I would definitely say use it for everything that you can think of.
Can it hurt someone? So that's another question that everybody asks, what if I use the rife and it, you know, is there a danger that my spouse doesn't have prostate cancer, so, you know, maybe we should sleep and separate fans.
The answer to that is absolutely not.
So if I'm running prostate cancer program on myself and my wife doesn't have a prostate, nor does she have cancer that it's just not going to help her.
So there's not going to be any benefit but there's not going to be any harm.
So there's, you know, in your programs, if you're running your nightly program that I created for you and you have, let's say, breast cancer, your spouse doesn't have breast cancer.
But that nightly program has other things other than breast cancer has other just, you know, different and no carcinoma programs, different carcinoma programs that can be beneficial for your spouse as well.
So even if you're currently with the ball and your spouse is still four feet away from you in a concise bed, they're still going to get benefit from it.
So there's a lot of things from people who say, wow, well, since my wife's been using it for her breast cancer, you know, my arthritis is better, or, you know, I seem to have more energy because when you use frequencies that stimulate body cells, your cells are going to work better.
And if your cells work better, you know, it's going to help you.
So the right by virtue of what it does, it actually functions also as kind of a low frequency P E M F machine, which if you ever heard me talk about P E M F machines, there's the low frequency kind and the high frequency kind so if you were in our office and you use P E M F in our office, you used the high frequency P E M F.
The low frequency P E M F don't have as much benefit as the high frequency P E M F. But if you do it for eight hours at a nut at a nighttime, it could have some good benefits.
So it does help and charge to your cell membranes. So remember your cell membranes hold a charge similar to a battery or a capacitor.
That's one of the reasons why the rife works is it adds self charge to your cell membranes. So it's hoping your spouse, even if it's not running specific frequencies that your spouse may need.
That makes sense. So certainly don't shy away from your spouse getting the benefit of the rife while you're using the rife, it just seems a shame.
So make sure that you explain that to them or have them watch this section of this video if you, if they're questioning whether they should sleep in the same bed as you.
There's also, you know, a way if you do tell me and you're doing better like with my wife, she's not in what she was in the throes of her melanoma, I had her struggle with the ball.
Well, she's not anymore. She's doing fantastic. So I actually reprogrammed our night program. So I'm doing we're doing cancer in every night, but we're also doing some other kids are programs. So is a preventable thing for us too.
So you can run programs that are then help that is more of a preventative medicine per se. So let's say I let's let's pretend that my dad died of prostate cancer, which you did it, but.
And then I have lots of prostate cancer in my family. I could run the prostate cancer program. No way that I don't think I have prostate cancer, I know signs of prostate cancer, but I could run the prostate cancer program to help prevent any cancer cells from starting because remember with any cancer, how long does that person have cancer before it's detected, you know, one year, two years, five years, 20 years.
Yeah, you like maybe the five year 10 year probably right so if I could start treating it with the right long before it ever becomes a clinically diagnosed cancer, I could not get cancer.
I could not get a diagnosis of cancer because I'm actually killing it. Log me for it gets to the stage of a diagnosed, wherever if it's the size, the cancer is the size of the tip of a ballpoint pen, it's not going to be detectable on a CT scan, even.
Or is it going to be detectable on a pet's get it at the size of the tip of ballpoint pen, it's already two million cells large. So the cancer has to be pretty darn big and pretty active and be going for a very long time before it's even going to be detected by even our gold standard of detection today. So just remember that so using a knife as a preventative tool is a very wise thing.
So if you have heart disease in your family, run the heart blockage programs, if you have, you know, different diseases in your family, you can run those programs, even though you're not diagnosed with those diseases.
So I don't want you to be tied to your right machine 24 seven, but certainly, you know, it's a good idea to create a space in our house.
I'm not really keen on having a TV out of your bedroom because it because of what it does to your brain and it helps doesn't let you sleep, etc.
But we have a TV in our bedroom. I'll confess because our bedroom is our right station too. So if any of the kids are doing well, my kids are getting much older now and two of my grown kids have a right in their house.
So it's about, you know, if they're not feeling well, we have two still at home, semi at home, and they go in and run the rife. So they can sit and watch TV or they can sit and watch when we watch, go and sit and watch football game, alter the rife on.
So that's how you want to use the machine. Now, again, if you've not ever run any programs, other than the ones I created, I challenge you to start looking at those and start deciding on some different programs that you can run.
Does that help? I don't know if I unmuted everybody here. So let me look here real quick if I did.
Pull this down. So I think everybody is muted. So let me unmute all of you guys have any questions. All right. So anybody questions so far?
But he's so cool. Okay, so let's move on.
So can the rife hurt anybody? We talked about that. There is one exception. So can the rife hurt anybody? Yes, it can if you're a live patient.
So if you have live disease, then you have to be careful. And that's everybody here has heard of what a herx reaction is. Yes, no, maybe. So herx reaction by definition is that if you kill something in your body, that you are producing what are called endotoxins.
And those endotoxins are then stimulated in immune response and or are overwhelming your liver detox pathways. So the only time that happens is with Lyme disease.
And there's some other tick board diseases that that could possibly happen. There's a tick fever that that could happen with.
But it's because Lyme disease is a berelia bacteria and its co infections are gram negative bacteria that have in their cell membrane.
They have a lipopolysaccharide, which is a fairly large chemical that it gets liberated when you kill it.
So these lipopolysaccharides get liberated when you kill the Lyme and they're big enough for them for the immune system to recognize and go, what the heck is that? Let's kill it.
And then you fire in immune response. And if you're already in an autoimmune stage, you understand that if you fire in immune response for any reason and you already have self antibodies, there you are going to kill that which you have antibodies against first.
So am I speaking too fast? Sorry. So if you have antibodies to your old tissue and you still stimulated immune response because you kill the Lyme too quickly, you will stimulated immune response that your immune system will then kill that what you have antibodies against which is your old tissue.
And that could make you hurt. So we don't want to do that. So we do have to go slower if you have Lyme.
So if let's go back to this slide, can you use the right for anybody? Will it hurt someone else? I tell you to use other programs and stuff.
But if you have Lyme, the only caveat is don't overdo the kill programs.
So if you have Lyme disease, don't overdo the kill programs. You can run a viral program, but don't run any more bacterial programs. Don't run any more Lyme programs than what I recommended for you because we never, ever, ever, ever want to hurts.
So does a cancer patient ever hurt? No. So don't worry about it if you have cancer. If you have Lyme, then no, then you don't want to run too many kill programs.
Does that make sense? So that's the only caveat in the use of the Rhyme. I'll use the Rhyme. Don't run too many kill programs if you have Lyme.
Does that make sense? So the Rhyme, the Rhyme is somebody of question. So the Rhyme is another tool in our tool bag.
It's a tool and it has to be used properly. It's not a magic one, but it's a great tool and it, it could be a lifesaver tool for people.
For Lyme patients, almost all of our Lyme patients recover. There's some that don't, for other reasons too, that are just get stuck and we need to go deeper.
That's why hey, hey, just so everybody who had this call knows next Monday, we're getting our acoustic therapy installed.
I am super, super pumped about this trying to stay very cautious and pretend I'm not too excited, but I'm cautiously optimistic that this is going to help some of our patients recover that don't have any other hope.
And just this last six months, we've had more cancer patients that are more gravely ill that I've ever had in my life that come to us that are just gravely ill.
And we've had a lot of Lyme patients that are very, very sick and whatever I hear about another thing that could possibly help people a little addicted, maybe a little obsessive compulsive, maybe any psychologist, but I want to find out if this is going to be valid and help people and I'm really excited about the acoustic therapy very optimistic about it.
I think it's going to be another tool that's going to really help people. So you don't know anything about that. This is all new to you.
Next week's call will probably touch on that and we'll go over that because that's going to be a cool therapy for people to be able to come in and do a couple of days of that could really turn them around, especially if they're stuck.
So contact us about that.
So there's another question that people ask, why do you use the true rife instead of another rife? Well, when I first got into doing rife, the true rife didn't exist at least I don't think it existed.
For a time I graduated chiropractic school in 1986, I was already a pretty expert in kinesiology, head of kinesiology club, really doing what was called this called functional medicine today, but it didn't have that name then.
And I was doing a lot of nutrition and I had studied a lot about rife's work. And for some reason I don't know, it was the Holy Spirit leading me, but I was so intrigued. I was like, I have got to have a rife. I just don't know why, but I just got to have a rife.
Well, I never felt like I had permission to buy one. They're expensive. And it's like we're going to say it's there for cancer patients. I just carpractor what I'm going to do with a rife machine, but I just have to have one.
So I researched it constantly and nearly pulled the trigger multiple times to purchase one. And I had by the one I wanted, you know, the picture of it up by wall, literally taped to my wall in front of my desk.
And it wasn't a tell. You probably heard this story. A gal came in who was a carpractic patient of mine who was tired. She was in her late 60s and told me that she had breast cancer and both her breasts and they gave her three months to live.
And that's what I just do. That was time to buy the rife. So that was the machine that I actually bought at the time was a light beam generator that was the best rife on the market at the time.
And then I also bought a galley Jeepers. What was it called? It was a different rife with a ball similar looking ball was the night tube, but it was a all DOS computer and programming was difficult and the power was like literally 150th of the true rife's power.
But so we use that. Those two rife's in the office that I had several other rife's that I used in the office. And again, when I first started using the rife, I only treated people in the office. Nobody went home with a rife.
Because that just was my paradigm at the time. And so we had really good success. And then I was again by OCD that's kicked in. I had to find better technology and more programmable, easier to use for a patient.
And that's what I came across true rife. And we started using true rife and our success rate went way up. And my good true rife is just an innovator. And he's constantly improving his product. So that's one of the reasons why I like working with him. I get no kick back, no benefit. It's just easy to program for my standpoint.
It's easy to use. And it works. I think it's the best way, the best rife machine on the market. Otherwise, honestly, I would use something different. So I hope this was valuable for you. I know that we got a number of people on the line that have questions that I have some questions that I want to go over if anybody else doesn't want us to scare to pipe in. You're unmuted. Anybody have any questions?
So I have a question. I don't know if you can hear me. I can hear you loud and clear.
Okay. Excellent. So I have an existing tumor that I can feel in my leg. And I swear in the morning after I do my rife, sometimes it feels bigger. But by the end of the day, it doesn't. Is that normal?
Well, I don't know that anything is normal. So, but what, as I think through the physiology, what could I think that could be happening? So if you're hitting the tumor with the right frequencies, multiple things are going to happen.
So you are going to cause that tumor to cells to vibrate.
You are going to cause those tumor cells, some of them to lice, which is the way some of them can die. And you are going to stimulate a immune response to that area.
So, could it feel bigger? Is that a good thing or a bad thing? I think that's a way good thing.
Because you're either one of two things are happening physiologically. Some cells are dying. So it's expanding and it's vibrating. So it's expanding.
There's this causing heat within the tumor itself and you're stimulating in a immune response. So it's expanding. So that's, this is one way the rife is killing the cancer and the whole, the whole purpose of the rife is to kill the cancer cells, right?
So, but if the rife, so what are the theories on how the rife works is that, well, you're hitting it with the frequency of the cancer itself and you're hitting it with the frequency of the cells.
If what are the reasons for the quantum physics perspective that a cell is, is, is, is multiplied rapidly is that it's not resonated at its normal frequency anymore.
So it's the cell. So if it's a breast cell and it starts rapid replication, it's not resonated at the same frequency that a normal breast cell should resonate at us.
So if you could hit it with the rife frequencies of the cancer itself and the breast tissue itself and that program that everybody's program can, is that one of the reasons why the rife works is that it's causing the cell to resonate back in its normal frequency.
So if you could hit it with the rife frequency, thereby not being cancer anymore, aka, not replicating anymore.
Does that make sense? Yes. I'll just try to dig through the physiology of it. You know, what physiologically could be taking place?
I mean, yeah, I mean, it's, it's not that it like feels bigger like I think it's growing. I just can tell that it's, I don't know, for lack of better word, a little more inflamed than, yeah.
And let's bring that up too, because somebody asked me that today is, you know, about inflammation.
So we always talk about, and I do maybe talk about inflammation is bad. Well, when I say inflammation is bad, what I really mean is chronic inflammation is bad.
Acute inflammation is good. So it's all, it's all balanced. So that's where we got to be careful of the internet and studying things and that, and that we want to label things as bad or good.
Right. But really, it's about balance. It's not about what's bad or good. It's about, well, too much inflammation to be chronic inflammation. Yeah, that's bad.
But acute inflammation isn't immune response. And if you're going to kill cancer, you have to stimulate an immune response. So do we want, you know, let's say it's a breast, okay.
Do we want inflammation around that cancer? Well, yeah, we do. We want acute inflammation around that cancer. This is why I've had numerous patients that have actually got really, really sick with the flu and put themselves into remission.
Well, how did that happen? Well, they got really super sick. So they stimulated this huge immune response and that knocked the cancer down and put them in remission.
So there was actually a therapy years ago, it's outlawed that a guy actually would put a number of toxins of different viruses. Hopefully in his desire would be not to give anybody enough of any one thing that they would actually die.
We put a little strep, put a little staff, put a little virus, put a little this in this, in this conction, it eject you with it. It was called Coli's toxins, because it was Dr. Coli.
And you would stimulate this immune response. You'd get really sick. You'd feel like you got the flu, you're throwing up, you're sweating, you're in bed, you're sick.
And these people would go into remission. And of course, it was outlawed. And hey, just about eight months ago, I saw that they're experimenting with it at Cleveland Clinic or something like that again. And it's all this new rage. It's like freaking eating me.
So stimulated immune response locally is possibly one of the ways the rife is working. So that's that is a benefit.
So you having that local inflammation for a short period of time, and that's how hyperthermia works too. So hyperthermia when we do hyperthermia in a person, you're stimulating this inflammatory response to that area to cause.
A whole bunch of T cells, your immune response cells, your killer cells, your marine core to get in there, thinking that, oh, this is there's a fever here, we need to get in here and deal with this.
Well, in the hopes that it's going to kill the kids.
Is that how?
Absolutely. Thank you.
Anything else.
So we had a couple other questions that were presented to me before this.
When I don't have a picture of it on the back of your rife machine, you have two things that are little transistors.
And for instance, my rife is about seven years old, I think, and I've never blown a transistor.
How would a person blow one of those transistors?
And on most of people's machine, you have a hot glued flipped upside down transistor hot glued out of the back of your machine with a piece of little foam over the little.
Wrongs that would stick out that have to stick in what you replace a transistor.
Why like a true rife includes that I don't know because I mean, literally in that eight years that we've used true rife, I think I've replaced a dozen of dollars.
But we have four, five hundred machines out there, so they're hardly ever replaced.
But when we've had to replace them, the most common things is that people had a lightning storm.
And the second most common thing is they accidentally ran the, ran the machine without the bulb plugged in.
So if you, you know, your bulb is plugged in the front of your machine, and if you've got kids in the house, they stay on the court or it gets unplugged somehow and you don't catch it.
That's what it can heat up the motherboard, and it can blow the transistor.
So just things to look for.
And one of the hints that I'm telling most of my patients lately, because we rearranged our bedroom.
And now we put the rife underneath our bed.
So that it will never stay on the cords. There's no chance that I can actually pull the cord out.
So that could be beneficial, but then I'm giving away my little secret that I never actually ever turned my rife machine off.
So I don't know if that's good or bad, but my rife machine has been on for five years.
Well, we moved our bedroom around, so I turned it off that. But so I never turn that power switch off.
The other mistake that a person could make that that could possibly blow their transistors. If they run the program on bath instead of bulb. That's easy to bump.
And if I decided the machine, I would make that switch a little bit more difficult to flip.
And I've never actually suggested that to Mike. So I like to suggest that to him.
Also, if I decided I'd remove all the lights, that's what I would do.
Okay, any other questions? Hope everybody's doing well.
We're going to have these every week. And currently they're going to be at four o'clock on Wednesdays.
And if they change, they'll be on the Facebook group. If you are not on the Facebook group, make sure you do get on that because that's where we'll have our announcements.
And these are going to be recorded too, so we'll put those up on the Facebook group.
And anything else before we say goodbye? Oh, you've been so good.
All right, if you have any other questions, any personal questions, feel free to call and get a time to talk to me. Thanks so much. Bye-bye.